غدار يا بحر اعرفك يا بحر غدار
من كثر الهوى
نهوى عناك ونشيله
تصفق ايدينا طرب يضرب لها طار
يا كمو كم باعد فيك من يوم وليله وياكم
فيك قطعت بعيدات الاسفار يا البحر الاحمر
ما لنا عنك ميله لو كان جوفك من الاسم
واخطار
[موسيقى]
انا ابويا وجدي جدي بخيت ابويا سالم عمي
سليمان عمي محمد العائله كلها كانت
اول فيها مايا بعدين انقطعت العين
خذت لها سنين مقطوعه العين بعدين سبحان
الله ردت العين فيها
الدوده كانوا فعل في ينبع النخل بعدين من
ينبع النخل جو هنا
نخل عندهم هناك وليمون وانا من اللي شفته
عندهم رحت قبل يمكن كم سنه كذا شفت بس
بعدين باع البلاد
عماني مع ابويا وجلسنا هنا الحمد لله وانا
من مواليد ينبع البحر الحين ينبع البحر
[موسيقى]
تطلعون احسن لكم ولا امشي واكبكم دحين
احنا
جايين هنا
الله يرحمه
الكتاب اسمه الكتاب في مدرسه ذلحين
كل محل فيه زي الغرفه سته
فانا سبحان الله مره كتب لي والله كتب لي
العلم يا ابوي اني ما ماني فاهم المدرسه
كتاب هذا قال لي امشي معايا فيا بيد
الوالدين البحر
البحر هذا البحر مش لعب
البحر هذا اول شيء علم
انا ما جبت البحر من راسي لا
انا جبت البحر من رجال شروه الطيبه طلعت
معاهم وتعلمت وكنت اسوي لهم الغداء اسوي
لهم الشاهي عندهم في المركب بنولهم اللعاب
بنولهم الحجر اللي هو الصقر
وحصلت لوحده مره واحده تكفى اداني ضربني
بس عشاني ما شنطت الفارس في فارس ملحوته
تاكل على وزر مش تاكل في الارض اللعب لا
فوق تعلق له التعليق فانا لما أولة تعليمي
عندما سويت بلحوت انا تاشتني كذا ما عرفت
اسوي كذا قمت ما ادري كيف سويت قال لي
تعال تعال ليه ما مسكت الحوته مضبوط هذه
اداني واحد كف خلاص بعدها فتحت وعرفت اني
عل وسرت يعني ماني مبالغ مبالغني طلعت ريس
في البحر الحمد لله
واجيب فارس واجيب صرع واجيب شعور الحمد
لله واجيب كل شيء نحمد الله ونشكره نجم
النجوم على الشمس لو انا الشمس ذي اذا
خليت الشمس على يسولك تروح الباحه معاذ
تعود هنا واذا خليته الشمس علي يمناك
فتردك البلد وفي الليل فيها النجوم نمشي
على النجم
ما تعرفش اللي في السماء
الله اكبر
مجرد الكبش يعني طريق طريق الكبش اللي
انزلوه مين انزله الكبش على مين على
ابراهيم يا رجل لما قال له اريت في المنام
يا ابني اني اذبحك قال له افعل ما تشاء يا
ابي
فانزل الله الكبش الله سبحانه وتعالى قبل
يخلد يدبر
تدبيره حلوه لا اله الا الله جعل لك صداع
علم الانسان ما لم يعلم
يلا هاليوم ترزقني وانا ما دريت رزقي
مقلوب بين المستوى الصباح
[موسيقى]
جيت هنا يمكن قبل قبل خمسه وخمسين سنه
في هذا المكان وست حوت وكنا نجي بالاشرعه
ما في مواطير نجي من البلد والمسافه كم
عشره
وناخذ بس مقلبين
لو تنزل انت في البحر يا الحوت من كثر
السمك
دحين ما في خلاص مو زي الاول
حتى واحد يختي علي اول البحر على الجلب
في سخاوي صغار كذا
ما تاثر على الحب سوى
حديد او خوا سعد يخش فيها الحوت تحط فيها
عجين يخش الحوت لا خش ما يخرج تجي انت
تشيلها تلقى فيها شويه اول السمكه
الصغيره اللي قد كده ما يجيبوها لا انها
هي دي اللي اللي تنمو
وسبحان الله وتجيب اولاد ويكثر هي ذي لكنك
انت امسك الكبيره
الكبيره دي خلاص انتهى زمانها رمت في
البحر 100 مئه اولاد مليون اولاد امساك
هذه هي تتمسك هذا هذا احفادها
احفادها يمشي في البحر عشان يتكاثروا
ويجيبوا سمك زي امهم
الله
[موسيقى]
احلى
لكن دحين جات حاجات غير السخاوي اللي
كانوا سووها الناس الاولين كذا كبرها
دحين خوا قد الغرفه
تدخل فيها حريقه بياض شعوره ابو قرن مدري
أخش كله يشيلها يطلعها
جبال الكحلي تفنيها المراويل
البحر
زي زي الناس
شيئا يموت وشهيا يحيا
سمك يحيى
قدار يا بحر اعرفك يا بحر
غدار والكسرات قالوا حتى انا من ضمن
الكلام جبت كسره
يقول
رحنا انا وعماد وليدي الصغير البحر ما
جبنا ولا حوت
اعرف انني اتكلم
قلت له يقول رحنا البحر ما لقينا حوت
غير التعب صار مكسبنا
ليه تفوت ولا البخت ما وقف معنا
[موسيقى]
ان شاء الله نطلب السمسميه
وبعدين يوقف الكف ذا يدق
بعدين يبدا هذا هذا يبدا يبدا هذا وهذاك
يرد عليه بعدين بالكلام نفس الكلام ما في
يخرج عن الخط هذا اللي حاضر شعراء
[موسيقى]
يقولوا ما هو طلب
منبعوه يا ابوي مشهور ذا معروف لما تروح
انت ذلحين تقول الدنيا شو ذي
سوديه ذا تقول له الدنيا طالب انجليزي
منبعها ينبع
من فنون ينبع
يعتمد على ايقاعات صوتيه من الطيران
ده يمكن له ربع مئه عام في 400 عام هذا
طلب قديم
لكن
دخلت ادوار مصريه معاه
[موسيقى]
اللي يقول مثلا زيك مثلا نقول يا حليوه يا
مسليني يا اللي بنار
الهاجريك وين دخلت بعض الاغاني
لا في بعض الاغاني ما هي ينبع بس دخلت
علينا احنا فمشينا فيها
وبشرك اني انا جوني والامس في البيت عندي
ان بعض المسؤولين
وثقنا هذا الغرام هذا الطلب أنا طلب من
بعوض
[موسيقى]
عليا
ولم يجدك
ضالا
فاغنى فاما اليتيم فلا تقهر واما السائل
فلا تنهر واما بن بربك فحدث انا
يعني تشوفوني اقولك مغني المغرب متى تغني
طيب
الليل الليل مهود العلوم
[موسيقى]
هذه خواطر
خواطر تجي على الانسان
الشعراء
كلام الله يقول اتبعهم الغول
وكل ارض يقومون ويقولون وما لا يفعلون
لكني انا شاعر تفضيل عن النفس
احفظه عن نفسي
وماني شاعر تراني من الشعار
[موسيقى]